>>Hello, I'm Pekka Puska President of World
Heart Federation. The reason why I'm here
at the World Economic Forum in Davos is at
health, in general, and employee health especially
is becoming very important for world and also
for world business leaders. And that is especially
true for today's economic situation. Heart
disease and stroke is number one killer in
the world. Every third death in the world,
more than every two seconds somebody dies
in fact somewhere in the world. At about 80%
of that is already in the developing world
mainly wrecking it's people. So at this World
Economic Forum in Davos, World Heart Federation
we call on world's business leaders to continue
and in fact to increase the investment in
health in general, to work together with health
leaders and particularly invest in the health
of the workers. It makes economic sense and
it makes humanitarian sense.Thank you.